>> Sean: ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION?
THERE WAS NO COOPERATION IN THE
FIRST ONE.
NONE.
>> IT'S NOT FUNNY, BUT IN A WAY
IT IS.
APPARENTLY ONE KICK OF THE MEAL
WAS NOT ENOUGH FOR
SENATOR FEINSTEIN, WHO I LIKE
VERY MUCH.
BUT HERE'S WHAT I WANT EVERY
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE IN THE
SENATE TO BE ASKED TOMORROW.
DO YOU AGREE WITH DIANNE
FEINSTEIN?
IF DEMOCRATS TAKE CONTROL OF THE
SENATE, ARE YOU FOR REOPENING
THE KAVANAUGH INVESTIGATION?
ARE YOU FOR MORE HUMILIATION,
GRADING TREATMENT OF THIS FINE
MAN, OR YOU FOR CONTINUING THIS
DEBACLE?
DO YOU AGREE WITH DIANNE
FEINSTEIN?
IF YOU GET IN CHARGE OF THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS HE WILL GO
AFTER KAVANAUGH AGAIN.
I THINK EVERY VOTER IN ALL THESE
TRUMP STATES THAT HAVE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS NEED TO ASK
THAT QUESTION, ARE YOU WITH
DIANE OR NOT?
>> Sean: WE'VE BEEN TALKING A
LOT ABOUT HILLARY COMMENTS, KICK
HIM ERIC HOLDER.
TWO POLITICIANS, REPUBLICANS IN
MINNESOTA HAVE BEEN ASSAULTED
AND PUNCHED.
ONE GUY SEVERELY INJURED, A
WOMAN PUNCHED.
MAXINE WATERS, CREATE A CROWD.
FOLLOW THEM INTO GROCERY STORES,
GAS STATIONS.
DEPARTMENT STORES.
THEY ARE NOT WANTED ANYWHERE
ANYMORE.
SHE'S GOING TO BE A LEADER IF
THEY TAKE BACK THE HOUSE?
>> I THINK THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Sean: AND YOU WERE SPAT AT
BY THE WAY.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
CAN'T WIN AT THE BALLOT BOX.
YOU TAKE THOSE OF US WHO DID WIN
A NEW TRY TO INTIMIDATE US IN
BENDING TO YOUR WILL.
I'VE NEVER HAD POLICE SECURITY
BEFORE, CAPITOL HILL POLICE
PROTECT ME EVER BEFORE UNTIL THE
KAVANAUGH HEARINGS.
HAD A GUY WHO WOULD NOT LET THE
ELEVATOR CLOSE.
I HAD TO GO TO MY OFFICE AND
SOMEBODY ON THE ELEVATOR PUSHED
HIM OUT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WOULD HAVE
DONE.
I HAD A BUNCH OF PEOPLE AROUND
ME FILMING ME, YELLING AT ME,
ALL OVER MY JACKET.
IT WAS PRETTY BAD AND I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE WHAT MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
WENT THROUGH.
SO THIS IS ON THE BALLOT.
WHAT YOU WANT AMERICA TO LOOK
LIKE?
ONCE THE ELECTION IS OVER DO YOU
WANT THOSE WHO LOST TO TRY TO
PHYSICALLY ASSAULT THOSE WHO
WON, OR DO YOU WANT TO HAVE AN
ELECTION ONCE IT'S OVER WE TRY
TO WORK TOGETHER AND GOVERN THE
COUNTRY?
>> Sean: IS NOT WHAT IT SHOULD
BE ABOUT?
AT THE END OF THE DAY AND
WILLING TO LISTEN TO ANY
DEMOCRAT, TELL ME WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DUKE TO CREATE JOBS.
TEN YEARS WORKING IN RESTAURANTS
STARTING AS A DISHWASHER.
TEN YEARS IN CONSTRUCTION
STARTING AS A HOUSE PAINTER.
ROOFING FOLLOWING THREE STORIES,
THAT'S MY BACKGROUND.
YOU GREW UP IN A BAR.
AND YOU HAD THE SAME KIND OF
BACKGROUND.
WE NOW HAVE 4 MILLION NEW JOBS,
400,000 MANUFACTURING JOBS,
BETTER TRADE DEALS, LESS
REGULATION, A PATH TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, THE BIGGEST TAX
CUT IN HISTORY, SECURING THE
BORDER, NORTH KOREA.
THINKING, WOW.
THERE'S A LOT AT STAKE HERE.
>> ISRAEL IS SAFER, ISIS IS
BEING DESTROYED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED A QUESTION
IN 2016, WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO
LOSE?
AND MOST PEOPLE SAID NOT MUCH.
THEY SAW NO HOPE WITH
HILLARY CLINTON.
LET ME TELL YOU IN 2018 IF THE
DEMOCRATS TAKE OVER YOU'VE GOT A
LOT TO LOSE.
I WANT EVERY DEMOCRAT RUNNING
FOR THE SENATE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION DO YOU AGREE WITH
DIANNE FEINSTEIN THAT WE SHOULD
REOPEN THE KAVANAUGH
INVESTIGATION IF DEMOCRATS TAKE
OVER?
>> Sean: DON'T THEY WANT TO
IMPEACH?
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH THE GUY.
>> IF YOU'RE RUNNING FOR THE
HOUSE IS A DEMOCRAT, DO YOU
AGREE WITH THE IDEA THAT THE
FIRST THING YOU SHOULD DO IS
IMPEACH KAVANAUGH?
THESE ANSWERS TELL YOU A LOT
ABOUT THE PERSON RUNNING.
SO THEY NEED TO -- ARE YOU WITH
DIANE OR NOT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE PLEASED
THAT WE GOT A GOOD CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICE, THEY ARE READY TO MOVE
ON.
>> Sean: THERE WAS ONLY ONE
DEMOCRAT THAT WAS WILLING TO LET
DUE PROCESS, THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
>> I WANT TO SEE WHO THESE OTHER
DEMOCRATS ARE LISTENING TO.
CLEARLY THEY DIDN'T LISTEN TO
THE PEOPLE OF THEIR STATE.
BUT IF I AM IN CHARGE AS A
REPUBLICAN, SENATOR GRASSLEY DID
A WONDERFUL JOB BUT I MAY BE THE
CHAIRMAN IF HE MOVES TO FINANCE.
I PROMISE YOU THIS, WE ARE GOING
TO INVESTIGATE WHO BETRAYED
DR. FORD.
I'M GOING TO FIND OUT WHY HER
LAWYERS DID NOT TELL HER THAT
THE COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE GONE TO
CALIFORNIA TO INTERVIEW HER IN
PRIVATE SO SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO
INVESTIGATE.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU'RE ONE OF
YOUR FINEST MOMENTS IN YOUR
CAREER STANDING UP FOR TRUTH.